I think one thing that above the law
adds to the legal profession is
transparency law firms and law schools
can't hide the ball from people and so
if they have problems whether it's
problems in terms of how they treat
their employees problems in terms of job
placement for their graduates problems
in terms of collegiality or partners who
are abusive towards associates we will
try and expose those and so in some ways
it's as Justice Brandeis said sunlight
is the best disinfectant and we are
trying to bring some sunlight to a world
that is often covered in darkness so I
think that that is a huge advantage to
be able to know about the what you're
getting into and make an informed
decision should i go to law school
should i work at this law firm or even
if you're a partner thinking of
switching firms you want to know what's
going on at the firm you might switch to
so i think that it has a lot of benefits
i think transparency and greater
information are the primary benefit the
secondary benefit which i think i
mentioned earlier is just the
entertainment value a lot of what we
cover is not particularly serious we
might cover industry developments like
layoffs or pay raises or in these days
pay cuts but we also cover funny things
about some lawyers some judge who did
something really hilarious and people
want to have that's that's something to
lighten up their day there is if there's
nothing wrong with making people laugh
especially in a profession that takes
itself very very and i would say too
seriously we do have an increasing
amount of cooperation from law firms on
layoff news what typically happens is we
will hear rumblings of it from people at
the firm who might drop us a line and
say we think layoffs are going down we
might then reach out to the law firm and
sometimes the law firm won't comment but
sometimes they will and if they haven't
notified everyone at the firm of the
layoffs what they might do is tell us
hey look we're going to be making this
announcement would you mind holding your
coverage until we can notify our people
essentially an embargo which people
which which entities do with news
organizations all the time and we are
generally willing to do that provided
that we can preserve our scoop
essentially
don't want them to say hold off on your
coverage and then they turn around and
they let somebody else know and
generally firms are pretty good about
about doing that other times we're
covering the layoff news after it's
already gone out we've been forwarded a
firm-wide email that announces the cuts
and in that case we'll just go and
publish it pretty quickly as long as we
think that the email is pretty reliable